hi everyone i'm jonathan trans and today
we're introducing a new series here in
the studio and this series is all about
opening traps so young players and all
players alike everybody likes to study
their opening traps they like the idea
of winning a game quickly and just
swindling their opponent into a very
fast and easy victory so today we're
going to be looking at the elephant trap
which is something that recently one of
our own instructors here fell for and
it's something that i've taught to one
of my students and they were able to
trap somebody in a game and he was able
to win that game so this is a very
relevant trap and let's go ahead and
take a look at it so we'll go ahead and
look at this from black's point of view
the game begins
d4 d5 c4 e6 and this is the queen's
gambit declined which i think it's
something that our beginners when
they're coming up with a defense against
d4 this is one of the very first
openings that they seem to pick at least
in my experience this is something that
everybody learns at first and it's one
of the most logical and solid ways of
meeting one d4 and so you're very likely
to get this trap because it purrs in so
many different games and whites most
logical move here is Knight to c3
putting a little bit more pressure on d5
and early in this game that's going to
be the big focal point so after black
develops his Knight to f6 a very logical
place for the night white will pin the
knight with Bishop to g5 threatening to
eliminate one of the defenders of d5
which means he's already threatening to
either damage blacks king side or to win
upon on d5 so black really has to
address this pin the most common way of
doing this is Bishop to e7 certainly a
logical move but there's also a trickier
move Knight B to d7 and what's really
nice about this trap is that even if
they don't fall for it and take the bait
on d5 you still will get a very
reasonable game and perhaps you're
intending to play the Cambridge Springs
after moves like c6 and Queen to a5
black will still get a very reasonable
game and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with playing this way but let's
see what happens if white goes ahead and
accepts first on d5 and in this position
okay he could play III or some other
logical move and not fall for the trap
let's go ahead and take the bait Knight
takes d5 this unfortunately runs
into a very strong move by black that
will ultimately win a piece so go ahead
and take about five seconds here if you
need to you can go ahead and pause your
clock if you want a little extra time to
think about it so let's all just chill
out a little bit and listen to the music
all right I hope you were able to find
the best move here
the amazing move that black can play is
Knight takes d5 and you're thinking wait
what a minute don't you just drop your
queen
well now black has a very nice move here
and hopefully you can spot this one the
move is Bishop to b4 check and
unfortunately for white there's really
only one way to block and that's with
the Queen and this position is already
very interesting because this has been
played in over 300 games at least
according to my database and just about
all of them with the exception of five
to ten games everybody has played Bishop
takes d2 which of course is a fine move
it definitely wins because after they
take we take their Bishop and we're up a
piece but what people don't seem to know
about this position is it might even be
more accurate just to take on d8 right
away okay black is completely winning he
is up a piece and he should be able to
go on and convert this a win the game
all right that does it for the elephant
trap hopefully you learned a new trick
that you can keep in your arsenal and
perhaps you'll get to use this sometime
in one of your games so if you like this
video please go ahead and hit the
subscribe button it only takes a second
and you'll get more great chess content
just like this thank you for watching